PROFESSOR: I think it's time
that we got started.
I haven't given a problem set
out for a couple of days.
So I have one that will cover
some material that we'll go
over with and develop today
and some new material that
we're not going to introduce
for a while.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, this
is Thursday.
And this is for the
near future.
I've given you two--
two a week before.
So it's the adjective you're
objecting to not the problem
set, of course.
Today we're going undertake
another major step in our
development of three dimensional
crystallographic
symmetries.
We have just completed
derivation of the
crystallographic point groups,
so these are the macroscopic
symmetries that crystals
can have.
And then, by analogy, to what we
did in two dimensions, the
next step would be to take each
of these point groups and
hang it at a lattice point of
some three dimensional lattice
that can accommodate them.
We have not as yet developed
the three dimensional
lattices, and that will be
our agenda for today.
Seems like we've already
done that, haven't we?
We showed that in two
dimensions, a cell can be
oblique, it can be rectangular,
it can be
centered rectangular,
it can be square,
or it can be hexagonal.
So these are the different kinds
of bases that one can
have for the cell, right?
So there should be the same
number of space lattices.
Actually it's more complicated
than that.
And let me remind you by another
handout what the two
dimensional space groups, the
plane groups, look like
assembled in all of their
glory on one sheet.
And there you see the different
ways symmetry can be
placed in these five different
kinds of lattices--
oblique, rectangular, centered
rectangular, square, and hexagonal.
Now a lattice in two dimensions,
a potential base
for a unit cell, can be
rectangular if and only if
there is symmetry
within that net.
That demands that it be
exactly rectangular.
In other words, if a lattice
is to be rectangular in the
base of the cell, it has to
have in it one of the
symmetries that correspond to
those in the plane groups that
give and require, indeed demand,
a rectangular lattice.
Similarly a lattice can be
truly square, identically
square, only if there's
a fourfold axis in it.
That demands that
it be square.
The same could be
said for either
threefold or sixfold symmetry.
One of the groups,
P3, [? P3, ?]
mP3, 1m, P6, and P6mm, has to be
in the base of the cell if
that cell is to have
the specialization.
So let's give an example
with a twofold axis.
Let's suppose we have a base
of the cell that has an
unspecialized shape--
two translations that are
unequal in length and an angle
between them which is a
general obtuse angle.
That's about as general
as you can get.
But suppose that this net has as
well a two dimensional-- a
twofold axis in it.
And suppose we pick our third
translation such that it picks
up this net which is going to
be the base of our three
dimensional lattice and
translates it over to this
point in the base.
Well that translation
picks up everything.
It picks up not only the two
translations that we've been
calling T1 and T2 to this point,
but it also picks up
all the twofold axes
that are hanging on
these lattice points.
So if this is the terminus of
T3 and projection, it will
have picked up a twofold axis
and plopped down a twofold
axis here where no twofold
axis exists.
And we can take one of the
theorems that we've seen,
namely that the operation A pi,
followed by translation,
is equal to a new rotation
operation through pi located
halfway along the translation.
And turn this around and ask
what happens when we combine
two rotations through
180 degrees
about different points.
And let's just draw it out
to see what happens.
Let's say there's a
twofold axis here.
It takes motif number 1,
moves it to number 2.
And then here's a second twofold
axis and this takes
number 2, rotates it over
here to number 3.
I is number 1 related to 3?
But in terms of this first
theorem, not surprisingly, we
have introduced a translation
into the space which is equal
to twice the spacing between the
twofold axes, which I"ll
label as delta.
So in other words, if we put
a twofold axis down in this
place in addition to the ones
that we already have, we have
created, in the base of the
cell, a new twofold axis in
this location.
That just mucks everything up
because it's going to rotate
the translations that we have,
it's going to rotate the
twofold axes that we have.
And we will not any longer
have a group.
We will not have a
set of operations
that closes upon itself.
So the conclusion then is that
if we're going to safely pick
a third translation, T3, and
combine it with a net that has
twofold axes in it, in order to
get a group, we are going
to have to ensure that the
twofold axes line up in every
net in the stack.
And there could be several
ways of doing that.
We could pick T3 so that
it goes straight up.
And then the twofold axes are
just all slit up parallel to
themselves, and they remain
in coincidence.
Or we could pick T3 so that it
terminates over the point
that's halfway along T2.
And then this twofold axis gets
picked up and put down
over one that's already there.
This one gets picked up and
put down over one that's
already there and so on.
So that's an OK choice.
That's a safe choice as well.
Similarly we could pick T3 such
that, within the plane of
the net, it had a component that
was one half of T1, so
that it picked up this net and
slid it over to this location.
So once again all the twofold
axes lined up.
Or, in the same fashion, let it
terminate over the center
of the cell.
So those are the four ways we
can combine an oblique net
that contains a twofold axis in
such a way that the lattice
points in the existing twofold
axes remain invariant and are
not moved into locations that
create new twofold axes.
OK so let's back off a
little bit and start
with plane group P1--
no symmetry at all.
So this is T1 and T2.
If there's no symmetry
whatsoever in the base of the
cell, we are free to pick the
third translation in any
orientation that we choose.
So trying to sketch it
in three dimensions.
If this is T1, and this is T2,
T3 can be in any orientation
such that not only is this angle
general, but this angle
is general, and this angle
general as well.
And if I would try to carefully
complete the
parallelepiped so that its
geometry looks reasonable.
This is going to be the general
oblique parallelepiped
with three translations that are
unequal in magnitude, and
three angles between
these translations.
Let me write them as the angle
between T1 and T2--
not equal to the angle between
T2 and T3 necessarily, not
equal to the angle between
T3 and T1.
And all of these angles are
completely general and can
assume any values
that they like.
So this then is the lowest
common denominator.
This is a totally unspecialized
space lattice.
It has the shape of the general
parallelepiped--
no special relations between
any of the translations
whatsoever.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I say they're--
Oh I'm sorry, magnitude
are not equal.
[INAUDIBLE]
I meant to put not equal
signs there.
Yeah, they can have any
length they wish.
They're not equivalent.
Any other questions?
OK let's go back then to the
case of an oblique net to
which we've decided to
add a twofold axis.
And that gives twofold axes in
the locations that we've
become familiar with
in the plane group.
And if I pick the translation
so that it goes directly
normal to the base of the cell,
I'm going to have a new
kind of lattice.
The lattice is going to have two
angles between axes that
are exactly 90 degrees, not
approximately so, but exactly
so, because only if that
translation, T3, is exactly
normal to the base of the cell
will the twofold axes in all
of these nets lineup exactly.
So here we have a degree
of specialization.
The translations remain
unequal in magnitude.
They can be any length they wish
and not change things,
but two of the angles--
axial angles, T1 to T2, is
identically 90 degrees.
The angle between T2 and T3
is identically 90 degrees.
And the third angle,
the angle--
I'm sorry, T1 and T2 is
my general angle.
So this can be anything.
So that can be any
general angle.
T2 and T3 and T1 and T3, want
to be exactly 90 degrees.
So we're getting space lattices
that have a degree of
precise specialization.
And the reason is that the
geometry of the base of the
cell is inseparable from
symmetry in the base of the
cell that demands the degree of
specialization that makes
the space lattice unique.
So let us look at a couple of
the other choices for the
third translation that will
leave the twofold axes in
coincidence.
Another choice would be to pick
the third translation
such that it terminated
exactly over
the midpoint of T2.
So here's T1.
Here's T2.
Now what I'm going to do is
something I have not done to
this point.
Having this translation T3
terminate exactly over the
midpoint of a translation
[INAUDIBLE] was clearly a
specialization.
If I were to go up two
translations, T3, I would be
directly over the end of T2,
and that is a much more
convenient way of demonstrating
that special feature.
So let me pick a new T3 prime.
It goes up exactly normal to the
base of the cell, and in
so doing, I will have defined a
cell which is a double cell.
And the catch is an extra
lattice point in the middle of
one of the pair of faces.
So I'll refer to this general
sort of situation--
this is a double cell.
And I'll call this, in words,
a side-centered cell.
And it has, with this
redefinition of translations,
exactly the same degree of
specialization as before--
magnitude of T1 not equal to the
magnitude of T2, not equal
to the magnitude of T3.
And it has the same
specialization of the angles.
The angle between T1 and T3
is exactly 90 degrees.
The angle between T2 and T3
And the angle between T1
and T2 is general.
General, but by convention we
will assume the obtuse angle
rather than the acute angle.
OK so by picking this double
cell, we've defined a cell
that has a twofold redundancy.
But in doing so, we have
gained the advantage of
showing that this specialized
geometry is exactly the same
as this one--
in the same sense that in two
dimensions, the primitive
rectangular cell and the
centered rectangular cell were
both cousins.
They were both had orthogonal
translations.
But the other thing that we gain
is that even though we
can't have an orthogonal
coordinate system, if we use
the three translations as the
basis of a coordinate system,
at least we have two
90 degree angles on
our coordinate system.
And operationally,
that is going to
be an enormous advantage.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So is T3 [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: T3 was selected so
that we picked it as 2 T2.
I'm sorry, 2 T3 minus T2.
That was my new T3 prime.
I went up two translations in T2
and then back T2, and that
put me directly over the lattice
point from which my
translations emanate.
AUDIENCE: So your T3 is
actually [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It goes to the next
level up in the stack of nets.
If I would draw this in
projection, which is not
nearly as clear in some
respects, this would be the
base of the cell.
Let me use x's for the
next level up.
So here's the net offset
by half of T2.
And then if I go up two of these
T3's and then back by
T2, my next layer up is directly
over the first one--
the third layer up is directly
over the first.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't it
be T3 prime then?
PROFESSOR: Yes if I were to be
consistent, I should call this
T3 prime, which I did here.
But now I should call
that T3 as well.
I got a little bit careless
because we're going to forget
that we ever had this T3-- to
find this selected as a
stacking vector.
OK well in P2 there
are four different
kinds of twofold axes.
So we could have the third
translation terminate over
either of the remaining pair
of twofold axes as well.
I think that it's apparent
that if I pick T3, the
original T3, as one half of T1,
so that the next layer up
terminates in lattice points
in this orientation.
And then I pick a T3 prime,
which is equal to 2 T1 minus--
2 T3 minus T1, I will
have gotten again a
side-centered lattice.
The only difference is that it's
going to be a different
pair of faces.
It's going to be the O1Oa faces
that have the extra
lattice point.
So that is not fundamentally a
different sort of lattice.
It is also side-centered.
And differs from our second
result only in whether it is
the side face with the shortest
translation or the
longest translations of the
base that bears the extra
lattice point.
One final choice though does
result in a new lattice with
special features.
And this would be one where I
pick the third translation
such that it terminates over the
center of the net below.
So let's let this be T1, this be
T2, and pick T3 so that it
moves the origin lattice point
directly over the center of
the parallelogram face below.
And then if I go up two
translations, T3, and then
subtract off T1, and subtract
off T2, I will again have a T3
prime, which is exactly normal
to the base of the cell.
OK this is a type of
lattice that you've
come to know and love.
In the cubic system, this
is referred to as a
body-centered lattice.
AUDIENCE: So then, T3
is just [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: T3, the original
choice, would pick this
original net up and move it so
that that net was moved--
such that it's corner was
over the center of
the original net.
So if we go up two translations,
we have lattice
point over lattice point, and we
redefine T3 by going back 1
T1 and minus 1 T2.
And that makes it exactly
normal to the base.
AUDIENCE: Not on the sides?
PROFESSOR: Nothing
on the sides .
Now in fact, if we try to do
that, we would have something
that's not a lattice.
If we tried to have some
additional lattice points in
the center and the edges of
this upper level, we would
have destroyed the original
T1 and T2 in
the base of the cell.
Let me do one or two more and
then I think the way in which
one proceeds should
be quite clear.
If you take this list of all
of the plane groups, if we
would like to have a three
dimensional cell that has a
rectangular base, the base can
be rectangular only if there
is a mirror plane in that net
or a twofold axis with the
mirror plane.
The two situations
are different.
So let's examine first the case
of a rectangular net that
has either a mirror plane
or a glide plane in it.
And they're both going to have
the same sort of constraint.
If I have a mirror plane, that--
let me use a slightly
wiggly line so the mirror line
is not confused with the edges
of the cell.
So here are two translations,
T1 and T2.
And if I pick a T3 that moves
this rectangular net up and
over itself, we have to do so in
such a way that the mirror
planes coincide.
Because if I have a mirror plane
in space that passes in
proximity to a lattice point,
I can turn my theorem around
and say that a translation,
T1, combined with a mirror
plane that is a reflection
operation that's removed from
the lattice point, I would
have to introduce a new
translation to delta which
is going to be
incommensurate with T1.
So I have to pick my
third translation
in one of two ways.
Let me indicate that by
drawing a circle.
T3 can terminate anywhere
over this mirror plane.
I could pick this net up, slide
it parallel to T2, and
as long as I put it down so that
this is the lattice point
in the next layer up, that will
be a legitimate placement
of the net.
Because all the mirror planes
are simply slid into
coincidence with one another.
So if I sketch that thing
in three dimensions--
this is the base of the
cell and it has
a rectangular shape.
And the third translation
goes up at an angle.
That's going to be
exactly something
that I've made before.
And the only difference is that
the oblique angle is now
on the vertical plane but
that's a right angle.
And this stays a right angle.
So that's exactly a lattice of
the shape that we had last
time with twofold axes, except
this cell is sitting on one of
its rectangular sides
rather than sitting
on its oblique base.
So that is something
that's not new.
And if I would pick the
translations so that T3 had a
component that was one half of
T1, plus some amount z that is
perpendicular to the base, I can
redefine that in terms of
a cell that has one pair of
faces inclined to one another.
And the difference is going to
be that the lattice point
would be caught in the
center of the cell.
This would be my original
translation T3 and I'll
redefine that as a T3 prime.
And that gives me two right
angles and one general angle.
So those are exactly the same
lattices that I obtained from
stacking a net with a
twofold axis in it.
Let me introduce now
another piece of
jargon as we go along.
The relative angles between the
translations are going to
determine the shape of the
coordinate system that we pick
along those translations to
specify the geometry of
features within the lattice.
So we've had a first case, and
this was just a general
oblique net.
So we had a T1 not equal to a
T2, not equal to T3, and all
three angles were general.
All three pair of axes
are inclined.
And this coordinate system, if
we want to refer to it in
terms of words, is called
a triclinic.
This is the triclinic system.
And the triclinic system is
short for coordinate system.
So this is as general
as things get.
And if this is the shape of the
lattice there is no symmetry.
Which is the same as saying that
the point group, the only
point group that can fit
into such a lattice,
is point group 1.
And then we hit another
sort of geometry.
And that is where the
three translations
had a general angle--
a third translation that was
exactly normal to the plane of
the first two.
And one pair of axes
is inclined.
And you can see that this
notation is a little strange,
perhaps, but consistent.
And it says something about the
nature of the arrangement
of cell edges.
So one pair of axes
inclined is called
the monoclinic system.
And this can contain lattices
that are either primitive,
side-centered--
with either the longest or
shortest translation in the
parallelogram that's
coming out of
the face that's centered.
Or we saw there was one
final possibility.
And that was body-centered.
So we'll refer to these lattices
subsequently as
monoclinic primitive, monoclinic
side-centered, or
monoclinic body-centered.
These lattices were compatible
with point group 2
or point group m.
We obtained a lattice of the
same shape with point group m
or with point group 2.
If it works for 2 and it
works for m, why not
both at the same time.
It would also work
for 2 over m--
twofold axis perpendicular
to a mirror plane.
Any question at this point?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Also 2m, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah
PROFESSOR: No,because as soon
as you got a mirror plane,
then you have to have
a rectangular net.
So it's going to be--
it's going to
fall into this family.
You're right, a mirror
plane by itself and
we've got that here.
That's where the mirror
plane falls in
the side of the thing.
You're right.
But if it has a rectangular
shape, then we have to have
either orthogonal mirror planes
and a twofold axis.
The base, if the base-- yeah.
OK.
Part of the amusing part of
this game is that you can,
upon appropriate redefinition of
cells, come up with a given
coordinate system that defines
more than one lattice.
And I'll give you--
because you get a little
space doing this--
I'll give you a two dimensional
example.
Here is one cell.
This is T1, this is T2.
This is a primitive cell.
Nobody should bother
to write this down.
Here's a T1, here's a T2.
So anybody know what that is?
This is a primitive cell.
This is a jail cell.
Couple sniggers, thank you.
Still another one--
this is T1, this is T2.
Anybody guess what that is?
That's a soft sell.
I got a million of them.
Know what that is?
It's an underground cell.
Here's one that's
kind of dated--
I don't think anybody
will get this one.
Does anybody know
what that is?
That was a misadventure of the
Ford Motor Company that was
named the Ed cell.
Well, I'll give you
equal time.
Anybody who, after intermission,
wants to respond
in kind, I'll let you have
an opportunity to do so.
But obviously these are not
standard crystallographic
cells, but they make
for a smile in an
otherwise dreary business.
I don't know how to
proceed from here.
I have a set of notes for you
which carries all this out in
incredible thoroughness.
So let me pass this around.
Let you take a copy of this
and we won't go over every
single thing, but I think just
to outline quickly the sort of
choices that we have.
We haven't yet finished with the
rectangular cell, but if
it's got something
like 2mm in it.
with twofold axes here
and mirror planes
running this way--
P2mm in the base, P2gm, P2gg,
can be stacked only in such a
fashion that T3 brings twofold
axes and mirror planes into
coincidence with one another.
So T3 could be 0T1 plus 0T2 plus
some amount z which is
straight up.
Or it could be equal to one
half of T1, 0T2, plus z.
That would be making the origin
twofold axis fall over
this location.
Or T3 could be equal to 0 plus
one half of T2 plus z.
And they're both going to, upon
redefinition, give the
same result.
Or T2 could be equal to one half
of T1 plus one half of T2
plus z straight up.
And upon redefinition, the
first one that would be a
brick-shaped unit cell.
That's going to be
a primitive cell.
Picking T3 with a component of
either one half of T1 or one
half of T2 is going to be
something that gives us a
cell, which can again
be redefined.
This was the original T3 in
terms of a T3 prime, which is
equal to 2T1 or 2T2
minus [? 2T3 ?]
minus T1 or T2.
This is going to be
side-centered.
And the final choice where it is
a T3 that's one half of T1
plus one half of T2 can once
again be defined in terms of--
redefined in terms of a
body-centered lattice.
OK this is a coordinate system
where all interaxial angles
are 90 degrees.
The translations, however, have
arbitrary magnitude with
respect to one another.
All of these cells could be
described as rhombuses.
In this case all angles in the
rhombus are 90 degrees, so
this is called the orthorhombic
system--
orthorhombic coordinate
system.
All the angles between the
axes are 90 degrees.
So we can get that out of any
one of the rectangular groups
that has twofold axes and
symmetry planes in it.
And conversely, take one of
these lattices and let the
symmetry elements that we
found in the plane group
extend through them and
you've got a three
dimensional space group.
So without emphasizing the fact
is we go along, we're
picking up a healthy number of
three dimensional space groups
as we go along.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: This is primitive.
It's also orthorhombic --
same dimensionality, three
translations, and they're all
mutually orthogonal.
That's true of these other cells
except they're double
cells in the case of the
side-centered and double as
well for the case of
the body-centered.
It's time we introduced some
other conventions for notation
in describing lattices.
We've been using T1, T2, and
T3 to designate the three
translations that are used
to define the cell.
One has to have some sort of
rules for picking a standard
unit cell so that two people
can do an x-ray diffraction
experiment, let's say, on a
particular material and end up
defining the lattice in
exactly the same way.
So let me now list, so that we
can use these labels as we go
along further, conventions
for selecting cell edges.
OK one convention is that one
should select the shortest
translations in the lattice.
And these shortest translations,
if there's no
symmetry, will be
[? dignified ?]
by calling them a, b and, c--
standing for the x, y,
and z directions.
One picks always, if there's
nothing special about the
translations in the triclinic
system, the magnitude of b
greater than a.
And in a rational world--
every so often you come to a
point like this and it feels
almost the silliest talking
about underground cells and
jail cells--
in a logical, rational
thinking world,
you would do this.
This is not what one does--
for reasons that have
to do with the
perverse nature of crystals.
Take b greater than a, one does
that always, but you pick
c as the shortest translation.
Why?
It has something to do with the
peculiar behavior of crystals.
If you were working with a
crystal that had the shape of
a needle, in other words,
greatly elongated in one
direction so that the crystal
looks something like this.
How would you draw a
picture of that?
Would you put it straight up
and down like this or would
you put it on its side.
Takes up a lot of
room this way.
You'd almost certainly
instinctively put it this way.
Now if you didn't know
anything about the
translations down inside the
innards of that crystal-- and
this was the position that the
people who did crystallography
solely on the basis of crystal
shape and morphology--
and had no idea if there was
even a lattice inside of the
crystal that caused this
regular shape.
When you draw a coordinate
system x, y, z,
z always goes up.
Who draws a Cartesian coordinate
system with z going
this way, x going this way,
and y going this way?
It's obscene.
We always put z going straight
up and down.
You do the same if you don't
know what the lattice
translations are with
the labels on
the axes of the crystal.
So this is a, this is
b, and this is c.
And there were tons of pages
published with drawings of
crystal morphology on them.
And then along came x-rays.
And when they begin to determine
lattice constants of
a the material that looked like
this, almost invariably
they found the translations
inside of a needle-like
crystal corresponded to
a unit cell in the
shape of the pancake.
Crystals, when they have a
very, very short lattice
vector, almost always grow most
rapidly in that direction.
So this is a terrible pickle.
Here are reams of books that
published descriptions of
crystals that had
a needle-like--
an acicular shape, if you want
to use a fancy term, which had
c as a direction which
corresponded to the shortest
translation in the crystal.
So what do you do?
You don't want to have to redraw
all these figures and
redefine all these directions
in the crystal.
So what you do is cop out.
And you make c the shortest
direction in the crystal.
You think this field is rigorous
but people wimp out
and they do something that's
contrary to the
logical thing to do.
Interesting question is why
crystals should grow most
rapidly in the direction of the
shortest lattice vector.
And I think I know the
answer to that--
I've never seen anybody express
it in the writing.
The clue comes from some early
work that looked at the growth
of the crystal from solution.
And this was done first with--
I think it was some
sort of iodide.
I can look it up-- something
like cadmium iodide.
And this material in solution
grew very, very slowly in the
form of hexagonal plates.
And continued to grow most
rapidly in this direction.
This was the direction of the
shortest lattice translation.
Then all a sudden something
happened.
And suddenly the rate of growth
and the nature of the
morphology changed.
The crystal took off like a bat
in these directions and
finally ended up in a
needle-like fashion like this.
This was an observation that led
to the dislocation theory
of crystal growth.
The interpretation was that in
the early stages of growth,
the crystal is growing by
accretion of atoms on to these
planar surfaces.
And the probability of an atom
sticking is less high when the
atom is on the flat surface than
when an atom is on the
surface that might have a little
crevice in it so it can
bind to two planes at once.
So the original postulate--
and now we all take
this for granted--
is that if there was a flaw
such that the crystal
developed a dislocation on this
surface, and an exposed
ledge, atoms would accrete and
stick more tenaciously to this
exposed ledge of the
dislocation.
And this is the so-called
dislocation--
screw dislocation mechanism--
for crystal growth.
And after the crystal has grown
for a while, you can see
spiral steps on the surface of
the crystal that correspond to
this dislocation
winding around.
OK so why should crystals grow
most rapidly along the
direction of the shortest
translation?
It's going to be a lot easier to
create a screw dislocation
with a Burgers vector for a
translation that is short,
rather than the translation
that's 10 or 20 angstroms that
the Burgers vector would
have to involve--
many, many layers of atoms.
If the translation is very
small, just two or three
atoms, it doesn't cost you
much work to make a screw
dislocation.
So I think that is the reason
why crystals with very short
lattice translations grow most
rapidly in that direction,
because it's easier to make the
screw dislocation with a
Burgers vector that's parallel
to that translation.
So here's the first flagrant
bit of logic that
flies in our face.
Let me give a few more
definitions and then we'll
return to this.
If we have a crystal in which
two translations are
equivalent by symmetry--
and we would have such a
situation if we picked a
translation that was
perpendicular to a square net.
And would we call the base of
the cell something defined by
translations a and b?
If this is a fourfold axis, what
goes on in this direction
is identical to what goes on in
this direction by symmetry.
And if these two directions are
identical, why call one of
them a and one of them b?
So if two directions are
equivalent, and this is true
of the square net, what you
do is call one a1 and
you call one a2--
because they're the
same thing.
So let's call them both a.
And the third direction
then is c.
And in such a situation here,
c is always defined as the
unique direction.
What do I mean by a
unique direction?
This is the direction of high
symmetry in crystals that are
based on square bases
and hexagonal bases.
Yes sir?
AUDIENCE: You pretty much
contradict yourself if c is
the longest [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Not always,
not always.
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean
in that picture.
PROFESSOR: Well I drew
it that way.
You know why?
Because if I draw it like
this, the top of my cell
doesn't get in the way of
the bottom of my cell.
And if I want to draw a small c
translation, then I get into
geometrical complications that
doesn't look nearly as nice.
AUDIENCE: Well, then I'm just
saying two [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
It's different for different
systems.
This is what is true for
a triclinic system.
And in the case of a
brick-shaped unit cell--
orthorhombic.
So this is done for triclinic.
It's also done for
orthorhombic.
Not for monoclinic.
For monoclinic, there is a
special direction because
there is a direction of a
twofold axis or maybe a
twofold axis perpendicular
to a mirror plane.
In that case, if we were
rational, we'd call that 1c.
OK
I'll close with an
opinion poll.
I will invariably, and I'm sure
most people do, draw a
crystal with a square base, with
the c axis the longest.
And if we have someone drawing
a sketch of a cell in which
the base of the cell is a
hexagonal net, we'd again call
one a1, one a2.
And perpendicular to that would
be the same direction.
Say look, there I
did it again.
I made c longer than
a1 and a2.
All right.
Let's look at hexagonal
crystals.
Let me ask for a poll.
What percent of all crystals
with threefold and sixfold
axes do in fact have the length
of c greater than the
length of a?
50/50?
How many would say equally
probable to have it the
longest or the shortest?
No opinion.
Let me tell you the
astounding fact.
Seventy percent of all hexagonal
crystals have c
greater than a.
Astounding.
Let's look at the next--
haven't really defined these
terms-- tetragonal crystals.
These are crystals that have
a fourfold axis in them.
What percentage have
c greater than a?
This is almost a first cousin
of the cubic crystal or all
three translations are equal.
How many would say more have c
greater than a, fewer have c
greater than a?
One vote.
More?
That's a good answer, but it's
only about 60 some percent.
So let's go down to orthorhombic
crystals.
And orthorhombic crystals
are the ones that have a
brick-shaped unit cell.
How many have c greater
than a?
It's declining.
So if you extrapolate 50/50?
AUDIENCE: Zero?
PROFESSOR: Who said that?
Are you a wise guy?
You weren't supposed to
give the right answer.
It's 0 percent.
It's 0 percent because there's
nothing that makes one
direction more special
than any other.
So you decide on the labelling
of axes on the basis of their
relative lengths.
And you, by definition, make
c the smallest axis.
Congratulations.
To the rest of you, gotcha.
So that's a good note
on which to quit.
And a few remaining mysteries
of coordinate systems and
lattices will be expounded
in the
second half of our lecture.